Hey venom is the next big upcoming
superhero movie with a recent trailer
that revealed riot as the enemy symbiote
and I a symbiote
the footage was definitely more visceral
in this trailer as should be the case
with a character like venom some images
may have major pinkeye yes turn yep yep
now we're learning that the studio
actually is now pushing for the movie to
have a hard pg-13 rating instead of the
R rating that we thought it would so
what would this mean for the movie venom
and Sony's spider-verse thereafter we'll
talk about venom but first welcome to
new rockstars news it's our deep dive
into all the biggest stories this week
so we're also gonna talk about Black
Panther and infinity Wars chances of
winning an Oscar updates on the birds of
prey movie in the Batwoman CW series and
James gun control hmm every bit it's
divisive oh yeah I'm Eric Foss joining
me at the table are Maude Garrett in
film alina hey guys and we would need a
fourth member for that quartet of the
barbershop Sam's not here don't worry we
didn't get rid of Sam it's we just have
had weird scheduling the past couple
weeks and Sam hasn't been able to make
those schedules but he's still with us
we miss him too and I couldn't make the
schedules we didn't acknowledge and no
one cared we all asked in our hearts
where's Philip - well let's get hard is
here or non-existent if you were made
well let's get started with our top
story venom recently a third trailer
came out for the movie which definitely
turned up the violence there were images
of Tom Hardy's twisted limbs
straightening out and venom threatening
to bite off a guy's limbs until he's
just a torso rolling down the street
like a turd in the wind
after his words she was very hard to
understand words that's a pretty choice
image that he had to put in her Minds
there and it's because this movie we all
thought was gonna be r-rated director
Ruben Fleischer promised that this would
be an r-rated movie and you know that
makes sense because venom is notoriously
violent and vicious in the comics he's
known for mutilation and cannibalism and
you know Fleischer is known for horror
comedies like zombie land so maybe you
could imagine him trying
to subvert this darkness with humor and
keeping the charm and the character
alive but now studio execs at Sony are
reportedly pushing for the movie to aim
for a pg-13 rating and to maybe push the
boundaries of what can be considered
pg-13 rather than embrace the r rating
according to different sources it's
looking unlikely that venom will keep
that R rating now the reason why they're
doing this is apparently to make it
easier of course to place venom as a
character in the future spider-verse
movies and it's definitely easier to do
that if the franchise as a whole is more
family-friendly it's kind of like the
universal language when you're trying to
transfer different currencies like oh
well yeah everything's ok it's a big
tent in the pg-13 category but the
spin-off films are they are in the works
so one is well first there's Sony's next
partnership with Marvel spider-man far
from home but in terms of their own
spider-verse movies there's Morbius the
living vampire it's starring Jared Leto
that was announced
there's also silk would be the first
Korean American super heroine she's in
the spider-man universe and just this
week it was announced that the upcoming
silver and black movie would actually be
split up into two different films silver
and black so they do have a couple
things in the pipeline there from a
creative standpoint my question to you
guys and for all of us is what is more
valuable to us a character staying true
to the memory that fans love from the
source material or character broadening
him or herself so that billions of more
fans can learn to love a version of him
or her and then maybe go to that source
material figure out where they came from
Tom Hardy's best stuff is not PG yeah I
agree with that Tom Hardy's such a I
don't know I think that sort of like
softening this and making it the appeal
broader is not going to help especially
with the character like venom look like
venom in itself is a predator he's like
sick and twisted and manipulative in a
way but he's also got teeth as long as
my face like been put like a soft thud
sorry a hard pg-13 that just sounds
wrong saying it together I'm hard P yeah
your doctor against every
thing III don't know I know why they're
doing it but I mean when you look at
Sony's other movies they've been fine
they've been great try something new and
maybe Sony is looking at their current
lineup a property and what does Sony
have they have a lot of like workings
with David Fincher who tends to do
r-rated movies
Tarantino works with Sony a lot so
there's a lot of r-rated stuff there so
they might be looking at like well we
don't have a big family friendly
tentpole franchise so we can't do
everything
no go ahead finish your point about
Smurfs there's it's too small to mention
just the idea that this idea of like
should we respect the source material or
broaden the character to be more
accessible that kind of people don't
realize like that did already happen
though for almost any of the characters
that you're aware of
I remember when venom was announced that
kind of like oh because they did an
r-rated version and they said they
wouldn't I was like oh cool and then I
thought about it and I was like well the
version of venom that I know I can think
of the examples you know I mean
straight-up cannibalism right like
that's kind of like the place to go with
that and it's like yeah those happened
and there are instances of that but I
feel like that's actually not people are
gonna disagree with me but it's not the
core of the character I discovered that
character long before I ever saw him do
anything like this r-rated so I do kind
of see if they do push a pg-13 I mean
some people have been surprising us with
what they could get into a pg-13 turns
out you know as long as you don't show a
woman doing anything she enjoys it can
still be but they really do like they
make it you know like guns can blow
someone's head up or I don't know the
exact distinctions or whatever but I
know it's yeah we we did some research
before this taping in terms of like what
exactly that the difference is between
pg-13 and our and how many times do you
guys you how many times do you think you
can say the f-word in a movie and get
away with it get one solid one you gets
one solid I'm gonna say - it's one who's
soft one who's soft woods but do you
know what a
there there's a specific caveat on it do
you know what that is if you stub your
toe
yeah but characters I like hit a coffee
table what they're saying put another
Dolly's in a swear jar I think I think
it's got to do with the noun or the verb
that that's part of it it has to do with
the context of whether or not it's
sexual so you can tell someone to F go F
themselves as well which is Wolverine
did in an x-men first class and that was
the one they got and then a Mission
Possible fallout Henry Cavill said why
you have to be so effing complicated
you get one but if it has to do with
like it could be a sexual connotation or
like we effed then that's a hard hard
immediately yeah yeah and and then
what's crazy about it is the whole
history of the MPAA if you look at
actually who's making these decisions
apparently as we as we found it is not
like a government body or anything like
that it's a board that's composed of a
rotating different group of like parents
that they bring in these people tend to
be very conservative and rhetoric they
are they are not only a ters police when
black people exist it's barbecue Becky
what kind of f-word was that there's a
really great documentary that we were
talking about that you should watch
called this film is not yet rated its
strict about John Waters who did the
original hair spray and pink flamingos
he's kind of a provocateur and he like
went after the MPAA and being like who
are the people who like to like submit
to who gets to decide who gets to watch
my movie and then I know right now the
ArcLight chain in Hollywood and in the
LA area is not abiding by an MPA our
rating for a movie that came over that's
Abigail Breslin gay conversion therapy
movie that they rated as our and they're
like screw anybody in come watch there's
a lot of controversy here but just know
that it's we're pretty weirdly
puritanical in my opinion here in the
United States in terms of things that
are of any sexual nature can get your
movie r-rated
but violence as a wide threshold of what
you can get away with
well I'm like what scars you right like
I can I can remember some of the most
vivid typical days I've ever seen oh
yeah ripping out a half remain like
videos that are on YouTube right it's
the violent images that I had to like
seek therapy I mean it's interesting you
mentioned temple gym I think that might
have been one of the 80s Spielberg
movies that actually brought about the
MPAA I think yeah they had to like
rewrite the rules from those movies and
people would start thinking like well is
this a family-friendly thing and
violence I think in Europe they're far
more sensitive to exposing kids to
violence than to sexual stuff because I
think in America we have a lot of like
mixed research on the direct link
between violent imagery and movies and
like real-life acts of violence and
really do your homework on that because
if there's not a real link I feel like
we're we're kind of like preaching to
the choir a little bit though with our
audience I'm sure you guys are pretty
with it about like these ratings things
so I'm just gonna throw out like a
little bit of like so what do we do
right
part of me is wondering is like we've
just made the MPAA not that long ago is
it worth like what if we didn't have the
MPA is it worth there being any bored at
all to decide like is there too far line
because there are some directors that
have said I actually realized later I
didn't really need to go to that extent
I kind of wish I got caught up in it and
I wish I'd done a little less yeah what
about if it's like the directors
discretion who did you make this movie
for boom this is the demographic of
people that I hired me based on that by
the way like let's have an agreement the
studio this is what I'm making it for
yeah and it was interesting Deadpool
came out this week and they have a super
duper cut and then you can see 15
minutes of extra footage that was
removed some of it was just for time
something was for pacing but so it did
seem like this is really extreme
violence that just seems to be like
celebrating this moment or like extreme
sexual jokes that might be like
offensive to certain groups because I
don't know I think we tend to get a lot
of laughs treating certain oral sex
between two men as a punchline and I
think Deadpool sometimes pushes that
line a bit too much that was okay in the
early 90s maybe now people are just a
little you know a little tired of it I
don't think the final movie did I think
they actually walked the line really
well but you could see the supercut
there are some jokes for him like
that might be why they cut that do you
know what a venom pg13 looks like Toyota
Topher Grace oh well you know what the
Spiderman animated series that was my
honest first exposure to venomous I
cared I'm like whoa this is a really
cool character I didn't I didn't read
the comics first as a kid I later had to
like discover them after the fact and
then if you really look at the history
of venom I think the more savage parts
of his history come in like later
incarnations like at one point flash
becomes his bully he gets the he gets
the symbiote and he was like and there's
other later versions that are like
soldiers who it helps repair their
injuries after war and some of those get
violent in different ways and there's
another version that like eat someone's
dog and it wasn't there's no like one
classic interpretation of venom one I
mean that we not eat your carnage to
like it has to do with the underlying
person which is interesting but yeah I
don't know that I say like they did
there aren't obviously nods to to and
being a cannibal in this
I don't know that like the movie needs
to be about that do you see him eat a
head off or do you used to see him pick
the bones you do it I didn't see the
Comic Con footage I was told at the
Comic Con footage do you do see venom
going for the bite but that made it's
you can't ever trust footage it's just
shot at Comic Con they changed all so
it's like a massive oil looking CGI like
I'm not I'm not gonna be scarred by that
thing gully
yeah unsee that so that's why I had to
drag you all into it with me
yeah it's I think a pg-13 version of
venom could really work I honestly I'm
more concerned about the idea of forcing
these cinematic universes than I am
about like yeah right into a pg-13 those
are the movies in the pipeline I don't
know how excited I am about those
they're kind of like well it's just like
drop one before you announce it
cinematic universe
yeah please well let us know what you
think about this radiance discussion
about the spider verse as the sony plans
to expand it should should Marvel really
just go back begging on their hands and
knees to get all these characters back
so we can just have them all in one big
happy family not think about it too hard
but I love the idea of Tom Hart
Tom Holland yeah just going at it yeah
but I mean just to tell it just warning
if it does come back to Disney there's
no guarantees that you'll get an r-rated
version of any superhero if it's under
the Disney umbrella they're very good
Kevin Feige is saying that from what he
understands there's room for r-rated
Marvel movies but there's a lot to be
seen let's move on to this week's a
trivia question what's really a question
we never do those okay so here we go in
venom the riot symbiote appears to be
attached to RISM its character Carlton
Drake head of the life foundation and a
lethal protector comic that this movie
is based on what is the name of the
mercenary who hosts the riot symbiote
okay all of our answers are here in the
easy easy inch cinch later in the show
we'll reveal the answer which I'm sure
we all got and the closest answer has
decided Burge I just will Jorge sign off
goodbye to the end of the video
meanwhile the loser who are taking our
new trivia punishment the latest
inductee into the gif of shame or jiff
of shame me wrong and stay tuned for
that later because you won't want to
miss it
okay guys this week the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences which
Awards the Oscars announced that in 2019
they will add a new award category
called popular film now it sounds like
this move is intended to be more
inclusive in the Oscar ceremony with
movies that general audiences actually
watch in large numbers and increase
ratings on the Oscars telecast itself
which is hit a ratings low this past
year the Academy said eligibility
requirements and other key details of
the popular film category will be
forthcoming but people have already
begun to speculate that this could mean
commercial hits like Black Panther and
Avengers infinity war could get
recognized they are probably the most
profitable films of this year
historically the Oscars tend to snub
blockbusters and superhero movies like
remember the Dark Knight was famously
overlooked and that that actually caused
them to expand Best Picture to 10
possible nominees meanwhile there are
some high grossing movies that have
broken through in the past to get Best
Picture like Titanic and Lord of the
Rings return to the king and many many
other popular films have actually gotten
nominated and last year a lot of these
popular films that would have been
nominated maybe
one for other awards technical words
just not the big time usually like
costume design custom design visual
effects sound design and then of course
over the years there have been movies
like you know get out and gravity and
Mad Max fury road and inception and all
the Pixar movies they tend to get
nominated
they just because they're that good yeah
now some of someone said that if this
award was available last year we would
have seen nominations for movies like
Logan and Wonder Woman in it so just
imagine that kind of let that be kind of
cool to see a category where those
movies are competing against each other
so overall do you guys think this is a
good idea if it means movies like Black
Panther and infinity war get recognized
by the Academy finally and what other
movies this year do you think should be
considered for this new category popular
film second one first Mission Impossible
fallout yeah oh so great yes it doesn't
get nominee one of the best action films
ever if they are gonna make this stupid
category then like like okay well it
still has to be like a really good
blockbuster movie and that was it wasn't
skyscraper just saying yeah I'm still
not sure don't even bother
no no um I think that it's kind of nice
that the Academy is starting to
recognize that they're just a bit out of
touch I mean this has been indicative
with the Oscars so white the last few
years now the fact that you know the
same kind of person it's like is winning
a lot of the time and that it's like you
know 400,000 people see a movie that
we've never really heard of I'm not
dissing phantom thread but it's like you
know you got all this love and attention
but I just everyone I spoke she wasn't
watching it so unless you're Alicia
Malone well I just kind of like that
it's like you know we are paying
attention to what is mainstream and you
know we're kind of catching up with the
times a little bit more instead of being
stuck in this sort of stuffy closet
which is all about moons Newt yeah but
at the same time I don't like the
corruption that's behind this decision
because obviously well an actress that
gets put on a Mickey Mouse ears you know
if an actor and actress wins the best
Academy for best actor or actress their
rate skyrockets and so it is you know
the prestige behind winning the award
and the accolade behind it means that
you can increase money so do they really
need sort of like more of a reason to
get its I mean money drives all this
stuff all right ABC is it sounds like
they're the ones who are pushing these
changes because they host the Oscars
telecast and they're promising and we'll
make it a shorter show will put more
movies in there that general audiences
would have seen so ratings will go big
itself more and better advertising there
they're moving them more boring things
behind the commercials that said I guess
I'll play contrarian today that'll be my
role I I don't know that we need this
category I think it kind of is like
crappy that I people are already calling
it the popcorn Oscar which just is like
well thanks for making me feel bad about
an Oscar and then it's like so the the
Dark Knight should have been nominated
obviously but also theirs is stupid I
saw a gif that kind of like changed my
thoughts on this and it was just it was
a gift for as a picture something but it
said like everything is all ready for
you this one thing is for them and I
kind of was like you know what what does
an Avengers infinity war have I mean
like it's like maybe you won't have an
Oscar but it's like but then phantom
thread does have an Oscar and they don't
have anything else so I kind of get that
like maybe the Oscars aren't supposed to
be mainstream maybe they're supposed to
be like how we should all pay more
attention to the arts and stuff I've
always been pressured I mean I was super
hurt by the Dark Knight not being
nominated that year but I think that is
more about stigma than like they need to
find a backdoor in God I just want more
actual great films nominated including
superhero films and comedies and horrors
get out yeah yeah I mean I see that I
think I kind of go back and forth right
because like if it had existed last year
get out probably would have won that
category it wouldn't maybe wouldn't have
been nominated or had a chance at Best
Picture and a movie this year like Black
Panther infinity war or fallout would I
feel like the way they kind of separated
right now with Animated Feature right
they created the Animated Feature
category and 91 Beauty and the Beast won
Best Picture and we were thinking well
of Animated Feature existed then it
wouldn't have even been in the they
would have separated it but ultimately I
think like it's easy because I feel like
I'm in a bubble with my friends and
we're all like living in Hollywood and
we go to Arclight and like going to the
movie theater is often like oh yes we'll
get our movie screeners or what we want
to see in the big screen we'll see
Stanley Kubrick's 2001 a Space Odyssey
and analyze it after it and it's easy to
be in that bubble even though but I love
infinity war I love like it I look I
think there's there's celebration worth
having for all movies that do really
well and connect with people and a movie
like Jumanji came out the new one with
the rock and we loved it I think if
you're looking at the craft in the
tradition that is Hollywood filmmaking I
think you need to celebrate all
different kinds of movies including ones
that might that critics might thumb
their nose is that it's being just too
broad but most people really enjoy I
just don't want to get into MTV
territory I think they really just text
this number and vote for your favorites
popularity contest
no no no we want a group of parents no
good because I think the MTV thing's a
joke and most of the stars don't even
bother going anymore so yeah I don't
know if they're trying to dissolve what
MTV has done with their awards and it's
just like I'm not entirely sure it
sounds like they are trying to expand
their demographic and every 13 B Oscars
I'm curious to see what the eligibility
requirements are do they determine it by
box-office gross - they term it by
budget of the movie right yeah like well
maybe submit yourself I guess a little
bit and I real quick on the note you
were saying like you can technically
still be nominated for Best Picture
but Erik's not wrong in that we all know
that a lot of times people get the Oscar
nomination like because of some other
reason like it's their time or that kind
of nonsense so I definitely think you're
right they're like you know what we
Best Picture but we have a new category
let's just do that I think you're right
it actually will the Oscar said no it
could be nominated for both I think
you're more right it probably won't get
on there but I think what's good about
it though is we'll have a category where
these chances where these movies have a
real chance at winning the top version
of that award great so people are now
tuning into the broadcast just to see
whether it's infinity war Black Panther
just kind of an interesting thing for
fans to tune in on but if it is here's
here's one thing on the side of doing it
give Marvel some freaking Oscars and
maybe the other people will finally be
like okay fine we'll do it the right way
because it'll be Marvel's oscar-winning
like Iron Man 6 yeah you know reimburses
I think what it could encourage is these
creators of superhero movies to do more
movies like Black Panther and Logan you
know like more heartfelt thematically I
think infinity war was a very thematic
journey of sacrifice that you saw Thanos
and mostly other characters make I think
if more superhero movies are made with
that kind of like emotional gut punch I
think that's a good thing and if an
award category on something like the
Oscars ceremony does that I think it
could be a really good incentive for
directors of those movies to really
focus on what do these movies mean and
how can I really have an emotional
effect on the audience which I think
lifts the tide for all the chips yeah
agreed I'm gonna put you guys on the
spot real quick give it to Black Panther
infinity war Black Panther
I would say Black Panther just because
they there's if any warden amazing
they're not taking away from fenneis but
I think that having Michael B Jordan in
there was incredible the costume design
what they did with like culture in
itself yeah yeah I for me black may
there's more of a true film
whereas if any more feels like more than
a film there might be a cop out but I
know it's true you can't it's not fair I
actually enjoyed infinity war more to be
honest but Black Panthers a standalone
movie that's very good infinity war is
like a cap like epilogue kind of thing
like it would it had to do the fact that
it works
is amazing yeah so but we shouldn't give
to say that's the best don't yeah yeah
that's true well let us know what you
think about this new category if you
haven't opinion at all and if you don't
have an opinion about the category which
of these where do you fall in this
debate of what is the most the best
popular film of the of the year because
there have been a lot of good movies
that are popular and have been very
high-quality critically speaking as well
okay we got an update this week for the
birds of prey movie that's the upcoming
Harley Quinn sequel which teams up with
other female villains and we know the
plot and the villain to these villains
maybe here's the movie's synopsis that
was released after splitting up with the
Joker Harley Quinn and three other
female superheroes Black Canary Huntress
and Renee Montoya come together to save
the life of a little girl Cassandra Cain
from an evil crime lord and separately
we now know who that crime lord is it's
black mask black mask is a recurring
villain in the Batman comics he's the
alter-ego of Romans Jonas a former
wealth wealthy heir obsessed with masks
and he runs the false face society gang
he wears an ebony skull mask that was
carved from his father's coffin and then
after a run-in with Batman to mask its
cause sirrah do his face permanently so
he's got this like black skull he's
pretty cool looking and some
incarnations black mask and his gang
scar victims to reveal their true face
this is more like a cult but then
there's also stories like wargames and
under the Red Hood where he's just like
a classic gangster trying to control the
Gotham underworld and kind of sounds
like the direction they're going in this
movie the new 52 comics black mask
becomes a legacy character that passes
on to Jeremiah Arkham of the Arkham
Asylum Arkham and he goes crazy and like
worships the mask it's kind of like a
split personality Jekyll and Hyde thing
but yeah so a very interesting story I
like the idea of like a rescue story
seems very simple and straightforward
rather than just like a team-up movie
that's all about like revealing who
these heroes are for the potential
spin-offs it sounds pretty
self-contained like once this missions
done they stay part ways which should be
kind of hopeful for me I want to watch
the mask again film mask which one
because
anyway I about that's real real quick I
just I somewhere in there in your
description like a Sin City vibe or
something or like a grind house five of
like like just seems like badass girls
are like gonna take on some pervert
basically and dismember him turn him
into a jelly bean which is the word for
something with no arms and no legs a
jelly bean it won't yeah yeah yeah
disgusting how do you know that Maude
taught me that word moments ago let's
move on to another DC update from this
week a bat woman in the CW air verse has
now been cast
the actress Ruby Rose from the giant
shark action movie that came out
recently the Meg she'll be playing Kate
Kane aka bat woman and Meg came out
already is it damn it I really want to
see it yeah we good yeah she's playing
that woman it this is in the arrow flash
Supergirl universe there's gonna be a
crossover episode on the CW and then
potentially a bat woman series that
would air in 2019 they have a showrunner
attached I think they're waiting to see
how across the RIP so it doesn't sure it
will be great and recent versions of
comics Kate Cain is an army Brad and
she's a lesbian she gets expelled from
West Point for her sexuality and a she's
a cousin to Bruce Wayne
I believe her father is Martha's brother
the Wayne's in the cane canes and she
becomes involved with the Batman family
about me Incorporated and female Furies
so yeah that's very exciting Ruby Rose
is very promising well cast person for
this part I'm pumped because of the
casting I went from 0 to 100 on that
yeah this is very exciting and moving on
we want to give you another update in
this ongoing James Gunn's story so the
guardians of the galaxy director of
course was fired by Disney last month
after a political enemies of his dug up
offensive jokes that gonna tweeted and
they pressured is need to take action
and in what seemed like a revenge
campaign after Disney at fired Roseanne
Barr
last week we reported that the cast of
the movie of the guardians of the galaxy
movies released an open letter asking
for going to be rehired to direct at
volume three and they didn't stand by
the offensive tweets at all but they
were just saying that Gunn had
apologized long before the story blew up
and they felt that he had long since
redeemed himself and he's a good person
in their eyes this week Drax
actor Dave Bautista we found a good
image of behind me here is sitting on
Drax the shoulder and Drax is sitting on
James Gunn's shoulders forever they okay
so Bautista Double Down he tweeted that
a Guardians without James Gunn was not
what he signed up for and that for him
it felt nauseating to work for a company
that would empower a smear campaign by
fascist cyber Nazis those are his words
and he said that he would be asked to be
released from his contract if Disney did
not use gun script for the movie which
he had written by the time the scandal
came out in recent days not only does it
sound like Marvel intends to use James
Gunn's vol.3 script but there are some
loose reports out there that show that
there could be back channels between
Marvel and Disney to reinstate Gunn as
director there's a lot of moving parts
to these but apparently the studio is
worried about schedule delays since
Chris Pratt's commitments to a Universal
movie are limiting the window in which
they'd be able to shoot guardians volume
3 and not getting a new director and
script ready would push back volume 3 by
several years and that would kind of
script their whole face for schedule so
they don't wanna do that
so also Gunn is reportedly now in high
demand to direct films at other studios
so there may be some concern by Disney
that maybe they need jerks to
manufacture drama and might lose a
talented director who doesn't really
that pose that much of a PR problem to
them going forward that may just be
what's going on behind the scenes we'll
see what happens next
I heard a rumor that this is actually by
Disney's design this exact way of
rehiring him that they got like they
said look we did it and then they had a
plan for how to get back to rehiring him
interesting they created a problem and
then they fix the promise he's not
exactly created the problem but that
they created this solution to the
problem then we're gonna have the cast
like that would be interesting I mean
that's definitely like connecting some
dots but I mean like Disney is a
corporate monster that I could see doing
us all like fools it's not like they
didn't know that they had this short
time window like an employer and we're
gonna be screwed they can knew that the
moment
yeah I what would that would be a little
surprising just because they did fire
him very quickly like the mic circuit
just want started to come up and like
within 24 hours they've had so but they
can conceive of that kind of game plan
well in advance yeah
obviously there's there's multiple sides
to this and you don't necessarily watch
us for our political opinions follow us
on Twitter for deeper thoughts on that
but let's be civil in the comments about
this story and and try to reserve
judgment until all this all the truth
comes out but now it is time to move on
to our new rock stars news you guys
tweeted this questions and now I'm gonna
fire them on my coast they have to
answer them as quickly without
hesitation as possible are you ready
sure Phillip at truce corn wants to know
why did you kill the snowman Phillip why
did you burn him to death with a spoon I
had to pick this what how did they know
I don't know you told the story on this
show before or she was going someone who
knows such shoe scorn she scored with
the inside info and I learned what fire
was and I applied it to my paper snowman
that I'd spent a month working on that
was in preschool and what did you do did
you do I said this is a lightning round
it is I came home and hung my snowman
that I've been working on the whole time
from the ceiling and then I saw him on
fire and ice cream and it was so sad I
killed me so why do you think you did
this fire is fascinating it's inspires I
wanted to see honestly if fire catches
yeah I bet my bet my mattress on my bed
I loaded on fire with a match recently
Oh leaning around thank you for that
Song of Ice and Fire Phillip no a tested
by Adam wants to know if you could live
in peace in any of the DC EU worlds
which would you choose Krypton the
mascara or Atlantis and Amazon with fire
arrows cuz I weren't so you sure you
want to live there you don't have
billowy underwater hair no I'm a Pisces
but I hate fish huh I won't go
snorkeling I don't want to touch she
said the water your stuff is already
dead right Eric at true genius but genes
explode like genes question for Eric
parts of the MCU quantum I think realm
reminded me of the other side of the
bookcase seen in interstellar or brand
communicating with young Ned another
time travel thing I think he's touching
on here the fact about sending the
message part of it so what one moment in
the entire MCU timeline would you go
back to and warn of the danger to come
ooh hmm okay
that's a good one so the danger to come
being Thanos right so what are what was
one moment that we could butterfly
effect to and prevent that one thing I
mean he's gonna get those stones one way
or another right so maybe securing the
orb and the power stone in a better
place than Xander which is so weak that
they didn't even make the movie would be
one I mean I could have just crushed the
mine stone yeah I'm I would say
telling Loki not to grab the scepter and
Ragnarok you know you're not the scepter
the tesseract right he grabbed a
tesseract and what do you guys do a to
me like what was Loki's plan like it
didn't look like he was he actually
wanted to Beach
rathe or he was trying to trick Thanos
so what did he think he was gonna be
able to pull on Tanis in that moment
because he gave His life essentially he
was gonna attack them well how do you
let the tesseract it just would have
been sitting there unprotected well the
whole ass guard got destroyed so it
probably would have been harder to mine
there to be floating to be floating
somewhere and I don't know they don't
really have like a lot of these things
yeah so I would say Loki leave it great
little man well thank you for those
questions there's a lot of good
questions this week so I actually saved
a bunch of them and I'm gonna use them
for future weeks true score nasty
someone who knows this right how do they
you must have mentioned that minute now
comes the time for a 15-second shout-out
where each of us has 15 seconds to shout
about plug or Ram about anything they
want I'll start here I'm doing a sketch
show on Sunday a live comedy show in
Hollywood if you live in a lower
California area in the Los Angeles area
come to the Acme theatre on La Brea I'll
be performing with my sketch team dad
jeans I wrote a sketch for it and they
casted me to play a very offensive
version of Lyndon Baines Johnson that I
I need some support too because I'm
worried the crowd won't be a fan of me
after the show but it's gonna be very
funny so if you live in LA come check it
out and message me if you want comps to
it cuz I can get you in for free
so my 15-second chat out I've been for
alpha book-club a show that I do
Wednesday nights at 6 o'clock on the
Alpha Network we are reading Harry
Potter and the Goblet of Fire so I want
to give a shout out to Cedric Diggory
because ok weirdly I was a shadow I just
came up with was - Harry Potter in the
cursed child really which focuses a lot
on century yeah I just saw it on
Broadway go see it changes theater if
you don't like theater I don't care it's
like it's theater and it's magic and
it's the most amazing first death in the
Harry Potter books and it was - the
nicest most undeserving guy and some kid
I know
wasn't just as it was so good and
there's like a line in the book where it
was like this would have been the first
win that Hufflepuff had in about 20 or
30 okay so just to pitch again cursed
child they deal directly with that
moment it's basically the question that
was asked to you if you could go back
and warn someone apparently made 25
million dollars in Australia in about
four or five days in Australia yeah
amazing well we'll go check that fifteen
seconds we've been bad about all never
to Cedric's and to Quirrell who also
does some but no one cares better yeah
all right well it's time to move on to
our trivia question that we asked
earlier ya know before I reveal the
answer our new trivia punishment just to
remind you all is the gift of shame or
[ __ ] of shame if you're a shame I'm just
gonna say that every time don't you it's
gif guy so here's what happens the
wrongest answer will have to draw a
Tasker adjuster from this gif of shame
box and they will perform that task
repeatedly not sponsored by this company
we have limited box office and then that
we're from that repeatedly
they'll have to pantomime it while the
rip the winner reads a goodbyes and then
we'll chant shame at you the other one
will your stupidity will be turned into
an animated gif which will blast out on
social media and punish you for your
trivia ignorance yep in venom yeah the
riot symbiote appears to be attached to
Riz Ahmed zkk Eric tur Carlton Drake had
a life foundation in the lethal
protector comic that this movie is based
on what is the name of the mercenary who
hosts the riot symbiote Eric thinks that
it's Teddy Kane
Teddy Kane come on
Philip says starts with a consonant
Chuck McQueen Layton McQueen's dirty
friend the most Native American name
[Laughter]
like a typical American bull I was like
God I'm a Danish spy my name is America
hot dogs
well Eric what is the answer in America
answer is Trevor Cole Trevor a winner
well who won then we'll start with who
won really more than Teddy Kane I would
I would disagree I actually can I robot
rebuked because the tiene C whatever
it's fine mod wins and I was about to
say you tribe even blood like I women
like your logic Eric lost being the
least funny agree to the rules of comedy
I want to be entertained the safest
dancer who's the loser the loser got it
ok ok yeah he said once already so use a
gif of shade go ahead and draw an ant
the thing that's wave like a pageant
pageant queen on a parade float but
you're worried a sniper's trying to
assassinate you
ok great so you gotta enact that
scenario right now shame shame model say
yep shame shame say thank you guys news
I just want to thank ok Sara gave us
we've got Maude Garrett here
hi there I'm Maude Garrett I'm Phillip
Molina at fimo who's on the show awfully
paranoid is this a new rock stars like
this video share it around and subscribe
can you rock stars for deep dives on all
the stuff things love you know how's
that gif gonna look in your bio next
week so sharing this crap silly